two taiwanese tech giants have done what
the island's government could not
secure covet 19 vaccines made by
germany's biotech
tsmc the world's biggest contract
chipmaker and foxconn
which assembles apple phones will donate
10 million jobs to taiwan
after securing their supply from bayern
tech a deal earlier in the year between
the german company and taiwan floundered
at the last minute
taiwan's government alleged it was at
the behest of china
now terry gore founder of foxconn said
this
of the new deal this batch of vaccines
delivered directly from the german
factory i believe
will help taiwanese society to increase
confidence
and offer respite in the face of the
pandemic
and for more i'm joined by dw
correspondent william yang
from taipei william terry guar in his
statement
stressing on direct delivery from the
german factory to taiwan
why is that important
well that's basically due to the
existence of a taiwanese law that bans
all the vaccines and other kind of
medical
substance to actually be imported
directly from china
so in order to fulfill the taiwanese
government's requirement
this this very specific negotiation
needs to fulfill the fact that
the vaccines will have to be
manufactured and delivered directly from
biontech's factory inside germany rather
than coming from the
distributors factories inside china and
so that also makes
one of the most a tricky aspect of this
whole negotiation which
took a few weeks in order for them to
fulfill and get everyone
every like stakeholder in this whole
negotiation on board
i suppose the root question here is how
are two private
tech companies successful where the
government
wasn't
so if we remembered uh back in january
there was actually a revelation by the
taiwanese government
uh stating that some outside forces uh
obstructed the process of their
negotiation with biontech directly
because as we know most of the uh
negotiation of the vaccine
acquisition is actually between the
government and the manufacturer
themselves
so because of some political
interference coming from
not directly naming china the government
decided to bring
in two of the most high-profile
international companies
coming from taiwan to represent the
government to directly deal with
both the chinese distributor but at the
same time
the german manufacturer and because of
the status of one of the particular
company tsmc
which is one of the biggest chip makers
in around the world
this whole negotiation immediately again
the interests of the entire world
and that also put a lot of uh i think
pressure on the german government to get
also involved
ensure that this whole deal and the
negotiation will not fall through again
because of
any of the potential political
interference and that vice versa
put also pressure on the chinese
distributor which
originally was basically uh putting a
lot of the
messages directly from beijing onto the
initial negotiation with
uh foxconn one of the companies that are
involved but once
tsmc got involved this whole negotiation
needs to be
raised to a level where political
interference cannot be
viewed or it cannot be seen as the
obstacle to prevent taiwan from getting
the 10 million vaccines
right now that's the politics of it but
when these vaccines do arrive
in taiwan will they be enough to help
with taiwan's vaccination program and
when do they arrive
in taiwan
yeah so uh so far the media and also the
experts are expecting government
officials are expecting this batch of
the
vaccines to start arriving maybe in
early september
and uh there are also planned uh arrival
of more astrazeneca vaccines from japan
and also taiwan's own order
and also more modern vaccines that is
based on taiwan's
uh own order so uh if we adding up the
10 million with the
a couple little millions that are coming
in in between
july and september that should also uh
increase the overall vaccination rate
for taiwan to more than half of the
population by the time of uh the
this 10 million batches arrive and that
is certainly going to uh
help improve a lot of taiwan's
capability of defending itself against
the
possible uh outbreak that is going to
happen in the future and taiwan is also
right now in the process of actually uh
calming down and containing the current
outbreak that we're seeing here
dw correspondent william yang in taipei
thank you very much for that
update